in today's video we will be explaining
all muzan's forms in demon slayer we
will start with his weakest human form
but in the later parts of the video we
will be covering his most powerful demon
lord forms it's weird to think that the
main antagonist of the series and the
demon king himself muzan kibutsuji was
actually a human once muzon was born as
a human baby during the haiyan era in
the early 900s it was stated in the
manga that in his mother's womb his
heart has stopped several times when he
was born his heart was not beating and
he had no pulse at all it was decided
that he would be cremated but that's
when muzon cried for the first time
showing signs of life growing up the
doctors told him about his rare
condition and that he probably wouldn't
live past his twenties not giving up on
him the doctor of treating muzon gave
him a special prototype medicine that
was never used before due to the
medicine effect muzon's condition
suddenly got worse and in a rage he
killed the doctor that was treating him
suddenly he realized that the medicine
started working and that it helped him
get a healthier and stronger body but at
the cost of becoming the first ever
demon with an urge to eat humans with
that one out of the way we can start
covering much more interesting forms
demon form when he first became a demon
muzon was faced with many different
challenges apart from needing to eat
humans to stay alive which he wasn't
bothered by he discovered that he was
unable to walk in the sunlight as doing
so burned him severely muzon saw this as
a serious problem and regretted killing
the doctor that was treating him before
he could finish his treatment on muzon
he remembered that the doctor was using
the rare blue spider lily flower as
medicine and decided to find the flower
himself he then went on to search the
entire country for the flower but
couldn't find it deeply troubled by the
fact that he couldn't find the flower he
started to create more demons and plan
to spread them in the world hoping that
someday one of them would eventually
find a way to overcome the sun he
discovered that by giving humans a small
amount of his blood he could make them
into demons muzon can also further
empower a demon by giving him more of
his blood enhancing their pre-existing
abilities however this is limited to how
much blood the recipient can withstand
and adapt to if a human were to take in
too much blood from muzon their body
would mutate faster than they can
withstand causing them to self-destruct
into one giant mass of flesh before
disintegrating into ash he created many
strong demons over the years like
kugushibu kaza hantengu and gave them
titles of upper moons as part of the 12
kizuki being the first demon in
existence he is by far the strongest
demon in the world and has developed
many different abilities over the years
one of the things that makes him the
king of demons is his demon curse
ability he possesses the ability to put
a curse onto demons that have
assimilated his blood if any demon he
created even utters his name out loud
the curse activates and destroys them
regardless of their original intent this
was seen with susumaru who had
accidentally said his name despite
having no malice or ill intent towards
him and was still destroyed by the curse
implying that the curse is automatic
however the curse can also be
intentionally triggered by muzon this
was seen when he killed nakame who was
manipulated by yushiro because of this
many demons serve muzan out of fear and
respect simply referring to him as that
man when necessary to speak of him
however it has been proven that if muzan
is weakened or someone has sufficient
willpower demons can break free from the
curse which has been seen with tamayo
and nezuko he also has the ability to
read the thoughts of those that he has
shared his blood with by simply looking
at them it was later displayed that he
could also send telepathic messages and
have full conversations with other
demons as well as seen when he was
communicating with upper rank 1
kokushibo to check how many hashira he
had defeated and to order him to keep
them at bay until he finished recovering
from tamayo's poison muzon has also
stated he can sense the locations of all
demons he created however the further
away they are from him the harder it
will be for him to interact and track
them muzon is also able to see through
the senses of other demons however this
ability is limited strictly to what is
in their perception so if a demon's
senses are fooled muzon is unable to
discern the difference as well having
lived for over a millennia muzon is
extremely clever and erudite since he
has five fully functioning brains it
most likely boosts his intelligence and
other mental capabilities such as memory
and cognitive processing he was also
able to evade the demon slayer core for
nearly a thousand years despite the
leaders of the core the ubu yashiki
family possessing great foresight and
intuition and has also used demons to
create distractions somewhere far away
when he wants to hide something from the
core as far as his pure strength goes as
the demon king he is immeasurably strong
this was shown when he killed a grown
man with a single punch to the face
causing him to fly back as well as
hitting a building and causing cracks in
it he was also able to kill all lower
moon demons in his weakened woman form
with ease although he is already
insanely powerful his true strength is
unleashed when he enters his combat form
which we will cover very soon muscular
form the next one on the list is the
form that we got to see during a few
scenes only during the swordsmith
village arc muzon sends two of his upper
ranked demons kyoko and hantengu to the
village so they could kill tonjiro and
other demon slayers as the battle ends
nezuku almost disintegrates in the
sunlight but then suddenly becomes a
demon immune to the sun something that
muzon had tried to find for over a
millennia after telepathically gaining
this information from hantengu muzon
gets so excited that he instantly kills
his foster mother while calling nezuko
the chosen demon as he enters his
abnormal muscular form he also enters
this form when kagaya blows up his
mansion and tamayo injects him with
poison even though it is not officially
stated anywhere we believe that muzon
can enter this form when he gets very
excited or very angry we also believe
that his power doesn't increase in this
form it's only a physical change combat
form muzon's combat form is where the
true king of the demons awakens when
fighting muzon can adopt a more
monstrous form with a dark red mask
covering his limbs featuring sharp tooth
wide mouths with his torso exposed his
hair becomes longer and white his speed
strength reflexes and power are greatly
magnified in this form to the point that
despite having lost a great amount of
stamina and endurance and fending off
tomo's human transforming drug he was
still fully capable of easily
outmaneuvering several low-rank demon
slayers and consuming scores of them
within minutes of emerging from his
cocoon what makes his combat form so
different from his normal demon form is
his body being able to shapeshift he can
stretch his arms and grow several sharp
blades in his extended forearms and
shapeshift his hands into several bladed
protrusions which he could then swing
like whips to easily tear his opponents
to pieces the sheer swinging speed of
his attacks is extremely fast and the
precision of his attacks is also
extremely accurate even three hashira
working together couldn't get close to
him later upon being further enraged
muzong grows nine spine-like protrusions
from his bag that extend into bladed
whip-like tentacles with them muzon is
able to drastically increase his attack
range and number of attacks in tandem
with his whip arms allowing him to
easily mow down hordes of demon slayers
and corner for hashira furthermore it's
incredibly difficult to read the
trajectory of each whip making it nearly
impossible to counter muzon is also
tremendously fast in his combat form
possessing movement speed and reflexes
that surpass all the upper ranks of the
12 kizuki combined he was so fast that
tanjiro and mitsuri couldn't even see
them and could only rely on pure luck
and instinct to evade his attacks he was
also able to keep up with almost a dozen
hashira and ashira level demon slayers
for an extended period of time all at
once while having his power sapped due
to tamayo's drug he was near impossible
to beat in his combat form even with all
heshira powers combined if it weren't
for tamayo's anti-muson drug the entire
demon slayer core would be wiped out in
a matter of minutes in his final
struggle for survival muzon was able to
transfer the remainder of his blood
along with his memories into a suitable
body turning his new host into a demon
and exerting his influence he
successfully did this with tanjuro when
he was on the verge of death restoring
his damaged body and causing him to
rampage against his comrades furthermore
this technique is compatible with the
host's own abilities making it so tandro
can not only use demon abilities but
also his own as he gains immunity to
sunlight and potentially the use of the
sun breathing this transfer however is
not perfect as tondro was reduced to a
feral state only attacking based on
muzon's desire to kill the demon slayers
baby form muzon possesses the most
powerful and advanced shape-shifting
abilities out of all demons in existence
not only can muzon change his appearance
effortlessly but he can also change his
aura and presence which can even fool
the enhanced senses of lower ranked
demons as the long battle between musan
and the entire demon slayer core was
near end the sun was about to come out
at any minute as the last ditch to
survive muzon turned himself into a
giant demon-like baby trying to run away
in this form he could crush vehicles and
could only be held down by the combined
efforts of giome the heishiro with the
greatest physical strength and dozens of
other demon slayers although this form
is shown very briefly and there isn't
much information about it we thought
it's worth mentioning check out this
video where we explained all of nezuko's
forms in demon slayer